Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live at the Rawkode Academy.
I am, of course, your host, Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at Crossplane.
But before we do that, there's a little
bit of housekeeping.
First, please remember to subscribe to the channel,
click the bell, get notifications for all new
episodes,
and remember to thumb the video, share it,
comment, get involved.
If you wanna support the channel, there are
various membership options available. You can check them
out on the YouTube page where we have
some live courses currently in flight looking at
InfluxDB.
Also, we have a rather active Discord server
available at Rawkode.chat.
There's nearly 600 of us on there now
talking all things cloud native, Kubernetes, EBPF, and
everything in between. So come say hello and
I look forward to meeting you.
Today's session is about Crossplane.
And I am fortunate to be joined by
a developer advocate at Upbound, the maintainers of
the Crossplane project,
Victor Farsek. Hey, man. How are you? Oh,
very good. Thank you for caring me. No.
It's it's it's my pleasure. It's it's really
nice to be get to do something together.
I've enjoyed your your DevOps channel onto YouTube
for a while, so it's nice to have
you come over here and join us and
say hello.
For anyone that's not familiar, could you do
yourself a little bit of an introduction and
tell us who you are?
Sure. So my name is Victor Farcic.
I currently work in Upbound,
company behind Crossplane
or the main contributor to Crossplane,
and I'm a developer advocate. Now in the
past, I did basically everything because
my career can be qualified as Victor gets
bored within a year, and then it changes
what he does.
And that change is either
within a company, and then it ultimately I
I
reach a point where the the the there
were no there are no more things to
do in a company than I changed the
company.
Right? So I've been tech lead, programmer, I
mean, developer,
tester,
lead,
product something, whatever, everything,
basically.
Nice. And
now I I've been outbound mostly because
I've been following and using Crossplane for
at least a year before
I joined. And then
I innovate, told about guys kind of like,
you should employ me. I like this product.
I think that's great that you found a
product that you liked and then just was
like, yeah. I should go work there. Like,
that I mean, that's how you take your
your interest and your passion and apply it
in a really great way. So nice work.
Thank you. We got a hello from Russell
who is loving your energy. So thanks you
for that. Thank you, Russell. And Thomas Lav
from Croatia says, I
guess.
Oh, Thomas Lavie.
There we go. Nice.
Alright. So
why don't
we we mentioned this to you, so now
everyone knows exactly who you are. But maybe
people are not familiar with Crossplane.
You wanna give us what what's the elevator
pitch? What what is Crossplane?
Controlplane
for everything.
I'm not sure whether that's official picture or
whether that's on the website, but that's how
I would explain it. Right?
And
so
think of it this way. Right? When we
manage infrastructure
services
and whatnot,
we are all almost always using CLIs, right,
directly or indirectly.
You without naming products, you execute some command
in some CLI, and that CLI talks with
an API,
which can be AWS,
Azure, Google,
Alibaba, Kubernetes, whatever it is. Right?
And what people do not really, I I
I believe, comprehend completely is that behind that
API, there is always a cross play. Sorry.
There is always a control play.
Now everybody knows control play. That's Kubernetes. Right?
We know control play from there. But there
is a control play behind the API in
AWS. There is a control play behind
literally any any
cloud vendor, right, at least those that I
know.
Now what we are trying to do is
create a control plane
to manage all those control planes.
So because we feel that there is a
strong need for those things to be open
source,
and there is a lot of confusion
about not confusion, but complications. Right? I need
to do something in Kubernetes. I need to
do something in AWS, and then I need
to jump into Azure and then maybe some
on prem and so on and so forth.
And the major difference
why control plane is important
for
everything
be seen in Kubernetes. Right? We we are
we are moving away from the idea that
I should execute a command to create something.
It doesn't matter which tool they're using, right,
or to update something and so on and
so forth. We are now deeply into the
era where all those things are managed by
control planes because they're doing more than responding
to commands, like, something. Right? It's more like
continuously
monitoring the state of the the actual state
of something, comparing it with the currents with
the desired state, and making sure that all
those things are happening all the time. Independently
of which order we put things,
how we define as long as we define
the desired state, planes are managing those desired
states. Right? And that's simply that's happening already
right now.
Whether you know it or no, it's just
that we are trying to kind of create
an open standard
for
control plane that will manage
everything, give or take. Right?
Nice.
So
I guess, you know, a lot of people
now they know who you are, they know
what Crossplane is, but they may wanna compare
it to other tools that are on the
market. Is it fair to say that Crossplane
fits in that same space as
Terraform, Pulumi?
Is it different enough from them that you
think it comes into a new space? And
what would some of those differences be?
So
to begin with, currently, it is in the
same space as our, let's say, entry point
pitch head for Crossplane is
is infrastructure,
but we are definitely not aiming infrastructure
being the
the only thing that Crossplane manages, and and
it's not.
So the scope is different.
And on top of that, it's
the API is different as well because
one of the things that are very important
to us is that
there is a single API to manage
things. And when I say single API, I'm
not now talking about Crossplane. I'm talking about
Kubernetes API. Yeah. I believe that Kubernetes
but people ask me kind of, what is
the main advantage of Kubernetes? Usually, people think,
hey. It can run containers. Right? To me,
the main advantage is the scheduler and the
API that sits in front of it. Right?
That I can define things,
the state of things,
and Kubernetes can make sure that those things
are happening. And that's not only applying to
our to applications, but to everything. Even though
applications are
beachhead for just like beachhead for
Crossplane is infrastructure,
but not the end goal, I think that
the same holds true for Kubernetes and its
API.
Applications are only the first step
towards total domination of Kubernetes API. Right?
And
those another difference is the the control plane,
the scheduler that I was talking about.
When
you use other tools
or most of the other tools,
you execute some command and something happens Yep.
Somewhere in the cluster or in your infrastructure
or whatever you're managing.
In our case, there is a
scheduler
with the control plane, with reco continuous reconciliation,
drift detection, and all the things that you
expect from Kubernetes applications. So they just apply
to everything else. Right?
So the in my head, at least, there
is a huge difference between I want this
to happen now,
and I want this to
continue existing and being in certain state
forever and ever or or at least until
I change my desire.
Right?
Yeah. I think that's really important,
You know, if we talk about those Terraform
workflows right now, you know, Terraform only runs
when the user asks it to, when the
HCL has changed. Like, if I use Terraform
to spin up an s three bucket and
it finishes and then I go delete the
S3 bucket, I don't have an S3 bucket
anymore.
Is the Crossplane?
Have in fact, because it runs on Kubernetes,
it has that continuous reconciliation.
It's gonna detect the bucket disappeared and then
recreate it for me. And I think that's
almost a superpower to a certain degree. Like,
that's that's what I want for my infrastructure.
Right? I mean, everyone must want that.
Correct. I mean, think of it like
you can reframe it saying that what I
what I'm doing with my applications, want that
for infrastructure.
And what we're doing with applications I mean,
not everybody, but we are all moving into
into Kubernetes domain for, if not all workloads,
but for some. Right? And
the same example that you said would be,
hey. If I delete two pods of my
deployment in Kubernetes,
those two pods will be recreated because the
desired state is to have whatever the number
is. And we are just applying the same
logic on infrastructure and services.
Awesome.
We got a comment from Tim Martin there
saying
two of his YouTube Kubernetes favorites on the
same stream.
Sorry. We are crossing streams. I hope that's
alright. I don't I don't think we're gonna
cause, like, a a time space continuum problem
or anything.
Let's see.
It's still time. Thanks for the kind words,
Ty. We really appreciate it. Thank you. Alright.
Shall we show people a little bit of
a Crossplane?
Sure. Are we ready for this? Yeah. Yeah.
I am. Let me move the browser so
that you don't see
infinite can you see me now? Let me
pop this over to my other scene.
Awesome. Your terminal is now visible. You are
live. Take it away.
Okay. So
let's say that I have this definition,
GKE YAML. Right? I'm going to start simple,
and then I'm going to complicate things later
on. Now what this does
is basically
uses Kubernetes manifest with
custom resources to create something called GKE cluster
and something called node pool. You can probably
guess from the names what those things are,
and it specifies some properties like, hey. It
should run-in US East 1. It should have
the latest version of the cluster.
And locations for the node pool are those
and some other parameters. Right? So this is
this is similar to what you would do
with other tools, just that we are here
talking about YAML, and I'm not not using,
I don't know, like, Pulumi, it would be
Go, JavaScript,
or TerraForm would be RCL. So so far,
this is more or less this is just
looks like a different format
of something that is very similar to other
tools. Right? The major difference is that I
can do something like I mean, there are
many, the major differences. But to begin with,
this is all Kubernetes. It's Kubernetes API.
So I can do something like apply
dash dash file name, JK. Right?
Now I already applied this before I joined
the session, only so that you don't wait
for long.
But, basically, you need to trust me. I
applied exactly the same
same command.
And then from there on, I can manage
this as
as if it's a normal Kubernetes resource because,
actually, it is a normal Kubernetes resource. I
can say, cube capital gets managed,
which is a
catch it all crossplane type of resource, and
I can see my resource is running.
You see that, actually, I prepared it last
night.
The status is you can describe. You can
do logs. You can plug it into whatever
you're using for Kubernetes today, which is another
huge thing that I didn't mention before. Because
you think about it,
apart from obvious
advantages of Kubernetes,
there is the ecosystem that was,
I believe, never seen before. We at least
in my career, I haven't seen any other
platform, if you wanna call it, have such
a big ecosystem.
So I could I could now manage my
just as a as a slight differences compared
to other tools, I could manage my resources
with Argo CD or Flux if I like
GitOps. Right? I cannot do that with the
other tools unless they move into Kubernetes area.
I can get metrics from into Prometheus.
I can do logging in the way how
I'm doing logging in general and do all
the stuff that you normally do with Kubernetes.
And as a result, I have here a
short of command.
You can see if I put it on
the different screen, you can see that my
cluster was created.
There are three nodes, CPUs,
and all the stuff. Right? This is a
cluster now running in Google.
Now
one thing that is
very important for us, and that's what we
call composites.
So composites allow you to
compose infrastructure
in a not not infrastructure. Compose everything. Infrastructure
services applications
in a way that they're
much easier to manage, easier to digest, and
so on and so forth. Because
this is this was the simplest example that
I could come up with.
And this is kind of like, okay. Kind
of an average person can understand this. Somebody
who is not a Kubernetes ninja or not
not proficient with the Google Cloud can understand
this more or less. But let's say that
I have that I want to create a
cluster in
AWS.
What would I need to do? And imagine
that I'm a developer. Right? I would need
to create an EKS cluster. I would need
a node pool. I would need a VPC
or a couple of VPCs, subnets,
Internet gateway,
and a bunch of other things. Right? It
gets complex very, very easily.
Now alternative, and this is where composites come
into play,
I can do something like this. I can
say, hey. How about you create your cluster
using something like this definition?
And now the name of the this resource
is, in this case, composite Kubernetes cluster. This
is completely custom.
This is imagine a situation where an operator
or SRE or whatever the role is in
my company said, okay. I will create the
composition. I will create the I will manage
the complexity of all that,
and I will create a completely new resource
type in Kubernetes just for everybody else.
And this one says, okay. I'm going to
reference something called cluster Google. Now for now,
imagine that I'm a developer. Right? I do
not know all the details about everything.
So I can select, hey. I'm going to
reference something called cluster Google. It could be
cluster
AWS. Actually, let me change it. Why not?
Let's
do this.
I'm a developer and say, hey. I will
actually I want to run my cluster in
AWS.
Cool.
I want to have
small nodes.
I do not know really whether that's t
two something or t two t three something
or whatever are the older variations in
in AWS,
I want to be as simple as small,
medium, large. Right? I want a specific version,
or I don't want to
specify anything because
I trust that whatever is the default makes
sense, the number of nodes, and a few
other options. Right?
Now
this is something that can be digested by
everybody potentially.
And what what the final outcome is does
not depend on me, does not depend on
Crossplane. It depends on people in a company
who
wants to provide services
to others. So think of this as shift
left, and I will show you later how
how all this
how what is happening in the background for
something to be as simple as that. Right?
So I'm going to save this change,
and I'm going to do now I'm still
a developer. I'm going to do kubectl apply
dash dash file name,
and the file is called cluster YAML,
and that was created. Right? And now I
can do something like kubectl get managed,
and I should see
stuff happening.
Actually, I should not watch because there's too
much output to fit on my screen. So
let's do this.
Now behind those 20 lines of YAML,
I got two
IAM roles.
I got one, two, three, four, five
policy
attachments,
a node group, a cluster,
a route table,
subnets,
security groups, Internet gateways, VPC,
node, and the okay. Those two are Google
from before, so I'm going to ignore those.
Right? So those are all the things that
I should have created if I wanted to
manage,
in this case, CKS cluster in AWS.
And I still did not go crazy. Right?
Things get more complicated than that in a
real world situation.
Now the bakehow all that happened
is that somebody before
created something like this,
definition YAML.
So that's somebody. Call it SRE. Right? Defined
a completely new resource type for me, and
it's call it's calling that resource type we
call it composite resource definition or XRD.
And the name of this
new resource is going to be composite cluster
composite Kubernetes cluster. That's the same name that
I used
previously in a definition when I was pretending
to be a developer. Right?
And there are some
some parameters defined, like version, note size, min
note count. Those are the same parameters that
I used before. Right? So somebody creates a
completely new definition of a resource
that explains
what are the things that
teams in a company
care about and what are the things that
they want to manage, like version, node size,
minimum number of nodes, whatever those things are.
And we are going to expose that to
them. And and and by doing that, we
are going to shift left. We are going
to make those teams autonomous so they can
manage their own stuff themselves without opening issues
in Jira and sending it to some other
people.
So making people self sufficient
by exposing them to the level of
requirements or obstructions
that they're comfortable with. Right? Some other team
might need 57 parameters. Right? It's it's whatever
you choose choose it to be.
So this is a definition
of custom resource
custom what is it? Custom composite resource definition
that will that became later on when I
applied it to the cluster to the control
plane cluster became the custom resource that I
used before.
And now comes the madness. Right?
Or different I'm going to show you different
levels of madness. Right?
Implementation
of that interface that I just showed you
for Azure
would be this.
Relatively small, straightforward.
You human cannot comprehend it because in Azure,
all you need is an EKS cluster. And
I'm talking minimum because Azure can become extremely
complex, but I'm really talking about the minimum.
If it's
where did I put it? GCP,
like the one that I used before I
started the this session,
slightly more complicated.
Those are all the things you need to
define no matter which tool you're you're using
more or less. And now comes, let's say,
AWS.
The simplest possible I could imagine for AWS.
Now let me go to the beginning
and show you what I had to do.
I don't think we have enough time for
that, I'm afraid.
We don't have enough time to go to
the beginning of that. Exactly.
Leakers, cluster, so on. It's a lot of
stuff. Right?
Now what is happening here is
this is partly
what you would normally see in other tools.
Like, hey. There are some parameters that you
need to supply when you create an EKS
cluster and version and whatever you need. Right?
And then there are patches.
Those are the things that typically would get
translated
in from what user specified in that YAML
that I started with
into
into what is propagated later on to this
resource type. Like, for example, if you look
at if you remember, I used node size
and I said small. Right? And here, I
am translating small to t two t t
three small and medium to something else and
so on and so forth. Right? It's nice
that you showed that. We actually got a
comment from Russell in the chat asking how
those sizes were mapped or configurable. So Yeah.
There you go. And you are kind of
in control. Right? This is not something that
is opinionated vendor specific. Like, we decided that
whenever people when I say we, outbound decided
whenever people want small nodes, it will be
t three
small. Right? This you are in complete control.
You as a person, necessarily, let's say, you're
defining those things
and so on and so forth. So all
those are defined.
There are some patches that overwrite values depending
on user input, and they're all grouped together
and end up being something like
what they showed initially,
which I believe was this file. Right?
So all what I showed you, the all
those hundreds of lines and something
from an end user perspective,
that's what
you get. Right? And I'm still using very
simple examples. Normally, I would add over there
maybe to
in that cluster, to maybe
if it's, let's say, EKS cluster, maybe I
would install some applications,
like system level applications, maybe from mid use,
who would be running there, maybe ArgoCity,
maybe additional stuff. Right? So it can get
much more complicated than that. But from end
user perspective,
the interface is whatever you define it to
be. Right? And that's what we call compositions.
And even if somebody doesn't know what
that interface is and let's say that whomever
created all that stuff did not document it.
You know? No Wiki files, no readmess, and
stuff like that. You can always do something
like this. Explain
composite Kubernetes
cluster
and recursive.
Now this requires slight understanding of Kubernetes, but
not really out of this world.
And you know okay. So this is actually
what my specification is. Those are the parameters,
bin node count, node size, version, whatever somebody
defined.
Off you go. Create your own manifest.
Be in full control of the things that
matter to you and leave the things you
don't care about but are still important,
like,
somebody else.
Right? So it's
separation of concerns and shift left in a
way at the same time.
Yeah. It's nice. It's like, you know, tools
like Terraform allow you to directly access the
API to spin up devices or clusters or
node builds, etcetera. But composite resources actually allow
you to build platforms within these resources and
distribute them and share them across your organization.
Correct. Correct. So if
I would simplify it greatly, you would think
of it as being equivalent of, Somebody creates
a Helm chart, and then everybody else can
modify
Helm values.
But that
that would be only partly true because we
are not talking about some properties file. We
are talking about Crossplane creating completely
new
custom resources
that can be used by anybody else.
Yeah.
We have a a question in the chat
from Thomas Lav, which aligns directly with my
interests. So Thomas Lav asks, what about bare
metal or on premise clusters? Crossplane support that?
So
I'm not sure about bare metal. I would
need to check the
check it. I could check it later and
get back to you specifically for that question
because
if the Google Crossplane
contribute contribute, I think, you will see all
the contributions. Right? So it really depends on
the community.
And if it doesn't support, then it's just
one pull request away from supporting it. Right?
So there there is an Equinix metal provider
for Crossplane,
so you can spin up devices.
And, actually, the focus of my work for
the last
six months has been provisioning Kubernetes clusters through
user data alone.
So while there's nothing directing Crossplane
provider now, in theory, you could do something
like this. So
I mean, as long as there is an
API that Crossplane can talk to, then yes.
Right?
Alright. Awesome. Thank you for that. And I
I think maybe one of your colleagues has
joined us in the chat. Grant has been
kindly answering questions as we as we run
along
at.
So
Thank you.
Alright. Awesome. So that's good to see. I
like the way those composite resources are relatively,
you know, not easy, but, you know, writing
the ammo is something that we're all getting
very comfortable with these days. And they've been
able to define them that way as a
combination of other resources within Crossplane.
Once it's done once, you just reuse that
as much as possible, and you've you've got
this kind of platform
provider, which is which is pretty sweet.
Exactly. It allows you to build your own
interfaces,
right, that fits exactly
Yeah. Your needs. Because every every organization does
this stuff their own little unique way and
being able to codify that in a way
that is reusable is something that is often
lost.
It's something I've seen in the past. It's
just that each team ends up doing their
own implementation,
their own way, and there's all these different
variances. And then eventually, someone wants to do
a security audit. You're like, why are all
these things different? And, like, being able to
codify it in this way removes that whole
class of problem, which I think a lot
of people need.
Yes. Especially when you when you run at
scale.
I can't tell you how many times I've
seen, you know, whichever tool is used, hundreds
so and hundreds of files that are doing
exactly the same, but simply because there is
a small variation
or simply because the teams do not communicate
with each other and so on and so
forth. Right? So you want to codify
what you explained actually fits the bill very
well. You want to codify all your
knowledge in a way and expose it to
an interface that contains things that matter and
are
not
repeatable all over and over again.
Exactly.
Alright. We've got a couple more comments and
questions.
So Ty says a Crossplane with Talos or
Sudero would be pretty sweet. I agree. Big
fan of Talos and Sudero, and that would
be a nice integration.
Yeah. We have a question from Andreas.
Is there a way to define a more
specific validations than just the data type? How
does it feel if you mistype small
after multiple field validations?
If you mistype small, then
that
then you would see that resource not being
created, and you would
have to go to the resource to describe
the resource, you know, and see in the
events,
like, basically, with any Kubernetes resource.
So we we are this might be important,
actually, to mention. We are intentionally not trying
to
build things that
exist in Kubernetes ecosystem. Right? Like, validations
are just we are just following what how
all the other Kubernetes resources are working, like
or same thing for logging or for metrics.
Or another popular question, which I don't know
whether it popped up there, but usually pops
up. Hey. Can you have conditionals? You know,
if else statements. And, again, we are really
trying to avoid those things because
there is this part of the ecosystem. Like,
hey. You need conditional. It's excellent. Kind of
like there is Helm. Right? Helm can do
those things. Can can can can template it.
And
so so we are really kind of trying
to avoid anything that is is not really,
really specific and nonexistent,
if that makes sense. It does make sense.
Yes. Andreas, if you wanna add anything to
that, feel free to drop back into the
comments, but I hope the answer helps.
So I quite I quite like that.
Obviously, the AWS one is is is rather
massive because although ETS is a managed service,
it is very far from from managed without
tools like ETS
control
or something like a composite resource with Crossplane.
But I love the simplicity of the Azure
one and the the Google one as well.
Like, they're so easy for people just to
be able to play around with.
Yes. I mean, give or take. Right? Even
the simplest one like Google
becomes complicated over time because it's not really,
hey. I need a cluster. No. I really
need a cluster,
and I need I'm inventing now a database,
and that cluster cannot be just JKE. It
needs to run something inside.
So it's it's always more than a single
resource.
Now
they can
what I'm trying to say is that it
almost always gets complex. Now the levels of
complexity depending on providers differ greatly. Right? Mhmm.
And,
yes, some are some are easier than others.
Alright.
Can can we do something funny
or crazy depending on how you would look
at it? Like, you've you've actually provisioned an
EKS cluster there. Is that correct? Mhmm. Yes.
I can let me let me double check.
Maybe I didn't yet.
Because another interesting thing about
AWS is the speed with which things are
happening.
The lack of speed, you mean?
You said it.
Yeah. I don't I don't mind being biased
on your stream. Pushing it towards saying it.
I think the median time for an ETS
cluster is around twenty to twenty five minutes.
It is. So
cluster is still not up and running, and
the node group did not start because it
needs to wait for the cluster to be
created. And this is another thing that I
think makes a difference between using a control
plane than, let's say, simple CLI. Right? I
do not have to specify dependencies.
Normally, I would need to say, hey. Node
group depends on cluster
because you cannot create a node group until
cluster is there, and that can also get
messy. In this case, we do not I
did not specify any dependencies because simply control
plane's job is to figure out what to
do and repeat if it cannot be done
and all that stuff. Right? Mhmm. But, yeah,
you will need to if it's something funny,
you would need to wait until AWS is
created, or you can tell me whether that's
something funny can be done in
Yeah. We yeah.
Well, no. What I'm thinking is, right, we've
we've got a couple of subnets there. Right?
So and they all say true true for
ready and synced. Now I I just wanna
show people what my favorite thing about Crossplane
is the continual reconciliation.
Like, can we just go delete a subnet
from the UI? Of course.
Of course. Let's do that.
Let me this is my account.
Submits.
Okay.
Here we are.
I think that let me double check. OBF
is one of them. Yes. Do you wanna
choose or
number? One to three.
Two.
There we go. Okay. This one goes out.
Bye bye, Submit. Yeah.
No. It cannot be deleted because Oh, I
just got a reference back. Okay.
Let's let's do this simpler because I I
don't wanna go into
AWS badness of
dependencies. You know, you cannot delete this because
it depends on that, and that depends on
something else. Let's do this.
Let's go here
and delete the node group. How does that
sound?
Yeah.
Go for
If I I hardly ever use the
console.
I don't know how how you do stuff
in
from from web UI. Here.
Delete.
What do I need to do?
Team.
Okay.
It will be deleted eventually, and then
give it a minute or something like that.
And if I didn't mess it up,
it should reappear.
So does that mean that on your CLI,
you could run kubectl get node groups?
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. Kubectl
get node
node groups. Right?
And right now, it's synced.
Soon, it will detect when when it's deleted.
I I will actually put it watch it.
Right? Get
node groups.
At one moment, it will change sync to
false and
sorry. It will change ready to false,
and
then it will change ready to true again.
Yeah. So that's
Crossplane as what it's just checking that every
one minute, four minutes, something like that. There's
some interval, right, of the factory There is
I think and it don't take me that's
don't take this as pretty in stone. I
think that the default interval
is three minutes or something like that just
not to bomb
providers with requests.
And
and it can be changed. Right? You can
configure what that interval is. That's hey. Look
at this. Ready false Yep. While talking.
And then
periodically checks things and make sure that everything
is synchronized and all the chess. Let's see
what's happening here. It's still deleting.
Man, you cannot even oh, no. There we
are. It's ready.
Nice.
That's oh, that that's the node inside the
node group.
This
is
okay. I'm definitely confused with configuration.
As I said, I'm not using web UIs.
Deleting still might be That we'll need to
wait for AWS to catch up for that
to to to disappear, and then Crossplane can
maybe go and try and create a new
one with the same name. So who knows
how long that's gonna take? But
alright. Cool. Yeah. It's just nice. Like, the
fact that it even noticed that it wasn't
ready and the fact that it's gonna be
able to resync and recreate that, I just
think it's a really cool property of Crossplane
that we we haven't seen
in this type of tool to date until
really Crossplane came along. So just taking it
sorry. On you go. Yeah. Sorry.
That specific thing, actually, I don't know how
far back you go. Right? But we had
it with Chef and Puppet
in a different way. Right? It didn't use
Kubernetes scheduler and all this stuff, and I'm
not now glorifying Chef and Puppet because that
would be the last thing I would do.
But some sort of reconciliation loop existed, and
after that, it was lost.
And now we have it again.
Well, I mean, I preferred SaltStack's take on
it with its high state and its minion
based check ins. But, yeah, you're right. Salt,
Chef, and Puppet did have agent based setups
as well, which would, on an interval,
rerun their their recipes and their manifests.
Exactly.
Yeah. You're right.
I was I mean, I was just trying
to be nice to Crossplane, but I take
it back. It's crap. I don't like it.
Okay.
So, I mean, we don't need to sit
and watch for that, Deline. Maybe we can
check on it a little bit. Was there
anything else you wanted to show us, or
do want me just to keep throwing random
stuff at you? Go random stuff. I like
that more than me having
prepared. I mean, I have random money if
can show and run. Right? But, hey, if
you have random questions, even better. Oh, yeah.
So let's, you know, put this on of
the lens. I mean and I am relatively
new to Crossplane, I've got this lens anyway.
But if I wanna get started, how do
I work out what providers are available? How
do I work out,
you know, what I can actually do with
Crossplane?
So
no. No. That's
wrong address.
Crossplane IO. Okay.
So getting started
is where you would usually go
and follow
follow the instructions.
It has I'll be honest. There are things
to be improved there, but it's a good
starting point.
And regarding providers, there are two, let's say,
types of providers.
Those that you see actually, let me make
this bigger.
Those that you and
let me
do
this.
Okay.
Those over here, right,
are the providers that are official.
And
then there are providers that are not official.
Like,
when I when I say official, it's kind
of strange. But let's say, providers that are
exist for a while, that are proven to
be working, that passed all the tests and
and everything that we expect them to do,
which does not make them perfect.
And then there is
what did I want to do now?
My keyboard is going crazy.
Crossplane
contrib,
which is where everybody else can contribute.
And, eventually, things from here will go go
to the docs.
Like, we recently
worked with Civo folks
and got a Civo provider, right,
And so on and so forth. Like,
I'm working right now on some materials that
I will probably publish
in in a few days, but I use
this one, provide us SQL that allows you
to do something with your databases no matter
where the where they're running. So there is
a decent number of providers
outside of the official docs
waiting to go into the docs.
Thanks.
So
there's also a I mean, you work for
a company called Upbound, and they've they have
a SaaS offering that allows people to try
this out relatively easily.
Is that Correct. Yeah. Wanna share a little
bit about that?
So, yeah, if you go to Upbound Cloud,
you have
you have basically a web UI that allows
you to do stuff.
And let me switch to the one that
I'm using today.
Oh, so you're you're using outbound cloud today.
Right? Yes. Yes. I I I did everything
from the CLI.
There we are. Right? And this is the
oh,
come on.
It will happen. Right? You can't,
you know, you can browse things.
I don't know why it's so slow. It's
embarrassing.
There we are. Right? Look. I don't know.
What did they do? We get something. You
can see the resources that are of certain
name or certain
phrases.
You can consult them. You can see that
all the providers that
are having like, for example, for AWS, those
are all the
types of resources or providers that we can
use.
Actually, the list is bigger because some of
them have, like, multiple
things inside.
Like, Elastic Compute has seven resources in total.
And then repositories
where you can package your configurations and your
code into a container, push them there, and
make it even simpler to use, you know,
users, teams,
security,
and all the things that usually enterprise
companies are looking for looking for.
And we are soon to release a version
of this that is
self hosted.
Actually, actually, there are three ways. Like, when
you create a new control plane,
you can have it oh, that was too
fast. I clicked too soon.
Right? You can have a control plane hosted
by us. You can have a control plane
self hosted.
That's Crossplane itself.
And the third option will be what you
see on the screen, the let's say, cloud
to be self hosted as well.
It is this is the hosted version is,
I think, especially helpful if you wanna just
if you just want to start and you
don't want to set up Kubernetes cluster with
Crossplane there, you just want to play around
fast,
hosted version is is brilliant. It just gives
you
instructions.
You get distraction. Actually, let's do it. Right?
Test one.
I understand.
Create control plane.
And now this takes a few seconds,
and you get the control plane only for
you in a way. Right? And all you
have to do is execute the command to
connect your KubeCuttle
with control plane.
Why do the control planes have a scheduled
deletion?
Because
we think of them more as a temporary
solution for free usage.
If you want to make it permanent, then
you speak without sales guys.
I got it. Okay. There you go.
Still fourteen days usage to kick the tires
across, play and play with the providers, start
building out your composite resources. That's that's enough
time to get a feel for it and
see if it's right for for you and
your organization.
There's another important thing we're really trying.
Nothing really
we are not keeping anything from Crossplane proprietary.
Right? We have we have things on top
of it like this cloud,
web UI, stuff like that, but Crossplane itself,
that's completely
so you you can go for free from
day one without really suffering at all.
Alright.
Okay. If you're watching and you have any
questions,
then please drop them into the comment section
and we'll do our best to answer them
before we finish.
So I guess we've got two things. Right?
We're gonna wait for this oh, there we
go. It's already ready, so never mind.
We now have our own control Crossplane control
plane that we can use.
And that just I I'm assuming that just
gives you a KubeConfig,
right, or something like It goes to your
KubeConfig. That's that's the whole gist.
We just need to connect your KubeConfig with
this.
This is
behind the scenes, this is a
virtual Kubernetes cluster in our Kubernetes cluster. So
we are stacking clusters on top of clusters
for every user.
I see. I I don't know if you
can go into implementation details, but I'm curious
if it uses vCluster, which is a pretty
cool tool in this space.
No. We are not for a couple of
reasons.
Actually, I'll to begin with, I love vCluster.
I think it's absolutely brilliant.
But we started
before vCluster with this or when vCluster was
not a thing or popular or whatnot. So
we have
we have investment in in when we started,
I think that there was no real solution
like vCluster.
And
the guys working on it have some security
concerns about vCluster.
Actually, not security concern. The bigger thing is
that
now that we built our own solution, let's
say, it is optimized
for exactly what it does. Right? While vCluster
is more generic.
Like, in that virtual cluster, we are not
packaging the whole Kubernetes interface and everything, but
only the things that Crossplane
needs.
It's highly optimized custom solution.
But big cluster is awesome. I love it.
Alright.
Let's let's check on the status of our
delete node group. I'm curious about that. Wonder
if Amazon's caught up yet.
No.
Come on, Adam. No. No. I I need
to refresh. I'm never sure which parts of
the screen are refreshed automatically and which
okay.
I I'm not sure. Tell me if I'm
on a wrong screen, but I think that
I'm on the right screen. You're on the
right screen. Yes. That has been recreated to
our node group.
Active.
It was deleting. So there are two possible
explanations.
Either AWS
gave up on deleting
and said, I cannot do it, and I'm
gonna make it active again.
Or Crossplane
detected that the there is a drift and
corrected the drift.
Nice. What is our It's the latter. What
does our get node groups show?
Get node groups, here we are. Yes. Sure.
Okay.
Alright. I fixed it. That's pretty cool. Yeah.
And in fact, you can I think the
the node group name changed? Right?
I I was I I did not really
pay attention, to be honest. And even if
it did, my brain cannot remember those random
strings for more than two seconds. Yeah.
We got a a comment and a chat
from Ty who says that you have some
great videos on vCluster and others. So, yeah,
I definitely encourage people to check out Victor's
channel. I will put a link into the
show notes so you can check that out.
Oh, thank you.
Alright. We have a question from Andres.
How do you manage credentials
for the providers,
and how can you restrict usage
inside of the control plane? So, like, if
there if I don't want everyone to be
able to spin up a JKE cluster, how
would that work? So that that's another kind
of like you know, there there are so
many differences or advantages depending on how you
look at it.
So in in in traditional solutions, right,
I mean, that's that's a wrong word, traditional.
Okay. Another solution. Let's not let's just say
traditional.
When you interact with, let's say, AWS through,
let's say, CLI, you
the user that is using that CLI needs
to have access to whatever will be done
in AWS.
Right? So you need to have permissions. If
you want to create a EKS cluster, you
need to have permissions for that. Your user
needs to be privileged and what's not.
Now in our case,
Crossplane itself
is, let's say, privileged user of your provider.
You as a human running kubectl commands,
you are claiming
certain resources in certain namespace,
or you don't have to. Depends really how
you configure it. So think of it as
yeah. Let's let's say when you claim volumes
in Kubernetes. Right?
Kubernetes
has information and out in can authenticate to
create a volume like
EFS or VBS or whatever it is. You
as a user,
an admin of that cluster gave you permission
to create certain volumes in certain namespaces.
Right? So you need to claim them. So
there are those two distinctions.
What you as a what you as a
person do, you're interacting with Kubernetes, and you
have permissions to create certain Kubernetes resources in
certain namespace.
So I could I'm not going to do
that now, but I could go and say,
hey.
There is a namespace Rawkode.
And in Rawkode,
you can create, let's say, resources GKE cluster,
but you I will never give you permissions
to create EKS cluster, right,
because I don't trust you with with AWS.
You've been too negative towards it.
And
on top of that and this is now
plugging back into
the whole idea of leveraging Kubernetes ecosystem.
You can combine
whichever RBAC you're using in in Kubernetes itself,
let's say, with policies like or whatever
you're using,
and further define
things like, hey.
Joe can
everybody in this day's space that can create
TKS cluster, but Joe can only do up
to three nodes.
And I don't know. Somebody else can create
after five
to five nodes. So whatever the rules are.
Right?
So if you combine Kubernetes
RBAC and
policy management with whichever tool you're using, I
would say that you're getting a level of
both simplicity for the end user, but also
control for others that is really not there
with
almost anything else that is not Kubernetes
friendly,
native, let's say.
Yeah. That makes a lot of sense. You
know, Crossplane is using the Kubernetes API. So
all of these things should be implemented using
the Kubernetes API.
Definitely. Yeah. You're
it's it's more like kind of you need
to think about it differently. Right? You're not
the question is not about the credentials in
AWS or whatever you're running.
The it's about credentials to create or modify
or delete specific Kubernetes resources.
For majority of users, there is only Kubernetes
API. Nothing else.
Alright. I hope that helps, Andreas.
And if you have anything else, drop it
into the comments.
Alright, Victor. Is there anything else you would
like to show us before we start wrapping
this up for today?
No.
If I got Razor, I will I will
will I will stay here for a couple
of hours, and I think that we have
a limit. Yeah. I think, you know, we
we pushed our luck deleting the node group
and seeing that coming back. So let's let's
let's take that as a success. And Yeah.
Kind of as as a parting gift. Right?
Just kind of as a parting gift,
I will delete the whole cluster.
And then
we'll see whether it will come back come
back by the time we wrap up. Do
you think it's gonna delete by the time
we wrap up?
Let's see. You know, usually, those are the
moments when I go and watch something on
Netflix, so I never really paid attention. Alright.
I cannot because node group is attached. That's
alright. I trust you that it works. I
I think we've seen what we wanted to
see with the node group. You know? I
think the the one takeaway for everyone watching
here is that, one, your interest in Crossplane
should definitely be peaked. And secondly, the continuous
reconciliation
and working with the Kubernetes API, which hopefully
you're already familiar with, brings a lot of
superpowers to your infrastructure. I think it's just
a fantastic,
fantastic product.
I'm gonna pop back over to our big
face mode. There we go.
Okay. It was so strange for me looking
at the blank screen all the time. You
know? But my terminal is. I would see
your face, man. This is better. Yeah. Definitely.
So, you know, just as we as we
kinda wrap up, is there anything that you
can share? Like, what are what are Crossplane
excited by right now? What are they what
are you guys working on? What's coming soon?
What challenges are you gonna solve next? Like,
just
Yeah. So the the major
effort, let's say, or push right now
is towards provider coverage.
We need to get close to %
for all the
all the major use cases. Right? So that's
kind of that's not really exciting. It's just
simply the first queue that needs to be
done. And there will be some very exciting
news about that very soon. I cannot say
the dates, you know,
otherwise.
Grant, the one that was in comments, he
he's listening on this.
He's he's the one above me. He's he's
going to do something bad.
And
so most most of the off effort right
now is in debt.
And then in
soon for next quarter, we are going to
have some very exciting exciting announcements,
but I don't wanna share it yet. So
boring stuff. Provide the coverage.
Boring stuff. Alright. Okay.
Well, yeah, that that that's cool. It's nice
that, you know, the provider ecosystem has been
expanded on and elaborated on. I think it's
just gonna open up a lot more doors
to people that wanna use Crossplane.
We got a thank you from Russell in
the chat.
Thank you, Russell. Yeah.
Alright. Well, we have no more questions. We
got we got a few more. Thanks. People
are telling us to leave now. I think
that's what that means when they start saying
thank you.
Victor, thank you so much for joining me
today.
Really cool demos to see composite resources
providing
essentially an abstraction or a platform that doesn't
really matter what the underlying infrastructure is. And
I think that's a really cool thing for
people to take away, that you can build
these schematics
for what a platform means in your organization
and use that Kubernetes API to show them.
Very, very cool Yeah.
All right.
And if any any last words before before
I push the button?
Try it out. And if you get confused,
then ping me on Twitter or LinkedIn or
whatever. Find me somewhere. Yeah. Find me somewhere.
Get the help you need. Slack somewhere in
Kubernetes or CNCF. Google me, and I'll help
you out. Alright. Well, thank you again, Victor.
Have a wonderful day, and I'll speak to
you again soon. Have a good one. Bye.